hi so my last video a lot of people
wanted me to do more and that's really
cool here's a bunch of comments
somewhere there's another thing the the
swearing thing a few people commented
saying the beeps were really jarring and
I shouldn't censor myself ok it denoise
me it's it's extra work for me because I
have to review the play and add it the
might I don't want to do it either right
but if I don't that means my videos will
get flagged and be monetized I'm not
mean losing money I don't ask for
donations I don't have a patreon I don't
have any of that kind of stuff so this
is a way that I can work for my mind if
if the swearing of or the censoring of
the swearing really annoys you that much
I'm sorry I guess you can just forget
about the series but I'm I swear a lot
so I have to add at the might until I
can until I can stop my brain from going
instantly to swear words a half to a
half they added the mic so
anyway that's just just to getting a wee
thing out of the way there
oh okay let's see SCP containment breach
right let's see what work I tested it so
much I've increased the game audio that
was a complaint as well and this face
comm was the thing I actually wanted to
do it anyway but couldn't figure out how
to do it the last time so I might end up
just taking this out later also I'm
doing this with like my stream and
softer I'm recording this with the
stream in software so I will be able to
stream this if I want okay so do not
enable intro sequence no right
alright I was like that logo for the
mouth awkward ID on a poster for gauge
which is the guy who does the
containment breach run felon which
should be released this year fingers
crossed
yeah I thought a poster with us will
probably see it anyway
right so these receive things so f5
being progressive right
is this so you just have to wit here I
don't really get what you're meant to do
I've never heard that before a like half
the fun with this is is plan it and then
reading the comments because everybody
tells me what I've missed
um explains the things that I'm confused
about it's brilliant it's not common
like your own personal guide to the game
right okay so I've never been in here
before
poor hava and the use of cameras or
video equipment is prohibited caution
is this gas or is it an airlock can hear
someone keycard is one okay somebody
said there's something to do with it
something to do with the doors I think
like it like if you go close to one of
the doors that 173 is behind the doors
will look either masked up of your
screens gonna mess up or something
I don't know I don't really understand
it so I can't open up
I can't open up
look also I need to start closing doors
behind me do so this was the last time
that I died was here hi he can get to me
is the old me I don't understand okay
before I go up the elevator I want to
look good bite a little bit more okay
admittance to authorized personnel only
I assume let's keycard yep
oh this opens okay so this is where I
was last time it's open this door I hit
that I hit it right so I can see if no I
wish somebody else told me to agent horn
from agent wilkinson nice frigging sight
I lost four times just trying to find
the main security hope what the hell is
with this place a man
- agent wilkinson from agent Hart I
tried to warn you it was a modular
design theory command cooked up
the sections installed as needed and
where needed it was supposed to make
expansion recovery a lot easier but it
didn't really catch on you'll get lost a
couple of times but you'll figure
tonight
oops wrong button I hope I'll figure it
I he steps I don't know what that was I
assume this is gonna come in handy cuz
there's a lot of gas
I don't know feed voice lines in the was
gas and so that's a key card right well
he ever done like the creepy I'll be an
audio up on this game as a genius
because it is genuinely scary hmm is
this the Taz legate place or is it I
don't know what's on seats it's not I
see him every time that's the Builder
bear there you go I know without night
[Music]
there you go that's not pretty beetle
and he's gonna be in there he could I
heard my own voice there my old buddy
mr. doctor its dr. strange reference
breather look I don't know what that is
yet all of you saying that I have to do
research on this game now I'm just gonna
leave it I'm just gonna let you watch me
figure this game oh it's probably for
straighten for the majority of these
book Hey oz this thought okay this is a
looping thing well is this just a bad
idea
the elevator appears to be broken link
so kind of let's close the door
no come even close the door oh it's a
room okay
oh is this a keycard level one okay
gotta start somewhere on a cup there you
go that's a couple recursive spatial
phenomena oh yeah I remember the name
another number or something that reads
SCP documents like can't really remember
the name bubbles there's like the
numbers of the SCP so much that's really
disconcerting night he had walking past
that all the time I don't know what's
level one key card though I don't know
what I can use it on
Rebekah's remarketed there you go
I told you this is why I need to bleep
myself
[Music]
this looks very 1:06
I was really suspicious 2:05 Euclid why
does it have to be dark keycard okay so
is this higher security
I don't like this
yeah
something started there the generator
started is not a good sign or is that a
bad sign
okay I see p12 keycards York lives
no did I close did I close that door
behind ya
okay cuz this keep on never lose the
doors
yeah I can hear I can hear him scuttling
a pipe
nope he's there somewhere I can hear the
like the stone Oh God
does not have been there okay who's the
eyes open right yeah that's a stressful
stressful
oh why but it was there already I just
thought I was closing the door so I
could blank yeah I called the elevator
okay I guess I'll just wait them know
every time I blink going through an
elevator No
okay this isn't going to bad is it
achievement unlocked show yourself
I know what that is
this thick going past today
[Music]
like I guess
mm-hmm
okay what I do now I throw a cup out him
stop stop shish still there does he move
a bite at least he has to move there
okay those doors don't seem to be
opening so I'm gonna run to the end
where I was before out if the door still
isn't open
show yourself that sound like me I'll be
back did Oh redacted where'd I go
redacted no no
this has been a long road to nowhere
at least I saved it would MIT idli it
was only like at the start of the game
but at least I saved right okay
well I'm gonna leave it here again I'll
phone in the comments bye
you